this is a Fox News Alert emergency crews  are responding right now to what they  believe is a series of gas explosions  that have damaged homes across three  communities north of Boston you're  looking at pictures they're from the  helicopter local police chief saying  there are 2225 homes on fire in Lawrence  in that community he says there are so  many fires quote you can't even see the  sky the Eagle Tribune newspaper in North  Andover reports that at least one home  has been destroyed several others have  caught fire  I made a problem with a gas line that  feeds homes in that area north end over  in Lawrence the newspaper reporting that  some neighborhoods were being evacuated  again it's not immediately clear whether  there are injuries we are following this  but breaking news gas explosion in three  Boston communities impacted there